hi I'm Ryan I am Jerry and tonight we're
gonna watch the trailer for oculus prime
transforming hi oculus a lot of people
have been asking that we watch this
trailer and I'm excited to watch this
trailer just because you guys are
excited to watch this trailer I'm
excited because it is apparently a bloom
House production oh really fan yeah I
got way more excited now yeah I don't
know who's in this film I don't know I
haven't seen it I don't know much of
anything about it there's a mirror yeah
I don't know [ __ ] about it but I'm gonna
watch it now that it's [ __ ] bloom
house who you know has done that that
recent party movie with those three
girls here at the back so one that is a
Friedberg seltzer movie that is the
dudes who did like epic movie and meet
the Spartans and disaster movie
found-footage party thing no no they've
done like better movies like Paranormal
Activity you know normal activity
sinister and city urge purge dark skies
which is a lot better than anyone gave a
good for yeah so now that I know that
I'm ten times more excited to watch this
[ __ ] it's rated R for terror violence
it's there's terror and violence but
there's only some disturbing image it's
it doesn't make any sense to me I mean
maybe maybe like terror and violence
could just be vile violence yeah but
maybe terror just means like oh there's
some spooky music and you're gonna jump
and stuff and then maybe you know
disturbing images or like here's a crime
scene photo of a bloated body of a man
who was drowned and mutilated like I
like the fact that it's rated R for
terror this must be very scary yeah you
never hope you never get that in like a
[ __ ] like rating system is like it's
radar because it's [ __ ] scary
I think insidious hey it wasn't our but
but still I think it said terror and I
was like yeah hopefully this is
terrifying let's find out you ever
noticed the green thing goes on there
wrestling studio made I made the call
tab and you can nobody live ah we have
established who he is
oh I think she's from Doctor Who pretty
it's responsible for at least 45 deaths
in the four centuries of its recorded
existence interesting wait so this guy's
live forever Oh Swee'Pea
horror movie ass ghost is gonna make me
scared Emir's
cool music and now it's be very crunchy
apple oh oh discussing oh so gross
Oh creepy yeah that looks pretty [ __ ]
creepy yeah looks that yeah I can't wait
no that looks like a horror
yeah I mean I like I like blue house cuz
they they seem to just specialize in
spook house movies of one variety or
another and that's a genius concept like
looking into a mirror and then like it
just it deceives your mind and stuff
like that it's [ __ ] scary
yeah I mean I can't quite tell what the
movies like about about but I'm
intrigued most sir oh yeah the basic
concept is really interesting to me
yeah the certain thing with plotting
characters is a little confusing further
than that
I'm definitely checking that out
actually I almost prefer that because
it's like I can't really tell what's
going on but the mood looks good enough
that I that I want to see this I'm still
scared even though not entirely sure
what's happening right now
what another weird thing is I've heard
reasonably good things about these films
that WWE has been producing lately
because they they did the call which for
the most part was good and they did I
think it's called nobody lives there's
something which I also heard was a lot
of fun which was like kind of a bloody
you know slash fest I'm intrigued by
them I mean sure I'm intrigued now too
I am intrigued I am fascinated I will be
there blown the house smart violence to
think about it like they were able to
show that [ __ ] on a green band trailer
where she bites into the glass is
[ __ ] that's all implication almost
yeah that's smart but it's like [ __ ]
like oh like that's clever yeah yeah I
like I like it when people can do like
be like tricky like that and like make
the violence like feel more eerie even
though it's not showing you a [ __ ] ton
of violence you know well yeah I mean
it's that's arguably what makes it
creepier is not what you show but how
you show it yes
and here's I'm gonna show this to you
someone told me I should reference the
subscribe button and ever since then it
has become the most fun thing for me to
do yeah can you click it please I've
always wanted to put like desperate
things in there like I'll suck your dick
if you subscribe